creedence clearwater revival the band
loved this song so much you'd open up
every
uh show with this song pretty much yes
you guys played at woodstock
you opened with this song you hated your
performance at woodstock and therefore
you did not put yourself
in the movie is that a blunder
i don't know that i hated it it just
wasn't superior
it wasn't really great because we were
in the middle of the night and all the
people were asleep
the movie was huge though when the movie
comes out yeah
and uh you see all the these guy hendrix
you know all of a sudden he's on the map
from this
and it was such a big thing to be part
of woodstock did you kick yourself in
the head and go why the hell didn't i
put
put the band in this movie no i i didn't
feel that way by the time that movie
came out the band had already broken up
so hey you know what screw it no but you
know what i mean that's such a legendary
thing and everyone who was part of
woodstock who was in that movie i've
talked to leslie west of mountain about
this they were at woodstock too
and his manager said oh we're not
putting you in that movie and he's like
oh i should have been in that movie
well now i me you know simply as some
sort of
uh documentary about the band it would
have been cool but
everything else we were doing was was
like gold it was magical you know people
really love this and all that
and during our performance at woodstock
you had a half a million people asleep
it was the middle of the night
and basically we warmed them up for
janice chaplin who followed us
that's right do you remember hanging
there was it was it a big deal to you or
you just it was
awesome yeah i wanted to set the woods
on fire you know
what it kind of what had happened though
was the grateful dead had
they were just before us and apparently
we didn't know this until the 90s right
we knew something was wrong but we
didn't know what well they all dropped
lsd just as they went on stage
at midnight and you know they got lost
for an hour they didn't play but they're
still on stage